manifestaciones inabituales en la mayor
planta de fabricación de iPhone en el
mundo los empleados de la empresa
foxcond en China protestaron este
miércoles exigiendo el respeto de sus
derechos en videos compartidos en las
redes sociales se vieron manifestantes
enfrentándose a personas con trajes de
protección blancos y a los gases
lacrimógenos de la policía
antidisturbios pero el gobierno chino se
niega a comentar los hechos no tengo
conocimiento de la situación que
menciona y esto tampoco es competencia
de asuntos exteriores la empresa
taiwanesa foxcon es el principal
subcontratista de Apple y emplea a más
de 200.000 personas en su planta
desdenyahu al sufrir una balanza de
casos de koi 19 en las últimas semanas
centenares de trabajadores en pánico
huyeron a pie la mayoría de los
empleados viven en dormitorios y han
sido confinados en el sitio que ahora
funciona en circuito cerrado en un
comunicado foxcom confirmó actos de
violencia y dijo que trabajara con los
empleados para evitar que incidentes
similares se reproduzcan china avanza
firme con la drástica política de cero
impuesta por el presidente
según Apple los encierros han costado a
la empresa hasta 8 mil millones de
dólares y han producido retrasos en la
producción del más reciente modelo el
iPhone 14